- Hi everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
We wanna welcome you to
our daily live stream.
This is just a way for us to stay in touch
and have interesting conversations.
We started during times of school closures
'cause obviously we're
all social distanced
and it's that much more
important to stay in touch,
but we think it'll be fun,
even potentially beyond
if we, hopefully we
get through this period
sooner then later.
I do remind everyone that
we are a not-for-profit
and the only way we're
able to do all of what do,
and especially all of the things
that we're trying to
around COVID-19 support,
is through philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
I do wanna give a special shout-out
to several of corporations
who've stepped up,
especially since the
crisis, Bank of America,
Goggle.org, AT&T, Fastly
and Novartis for stepping up
and the many other supporters before that.
We can't do this work,
many of y'all might wonder,
"how is this free," it's because of
those philanthropic
donations and Khan Academy
is much more than myself,
it's over 200 full-time folks
working around the world and
obviously we need resources
in order to do this work.
So I'm super excited about today's guest.
I have Kellye Testy
from the Law School
Admission Council joining us
and Kellye good to see you.
- It's great to see you and
so great to be with you.
We love the Khan Academy.
- And we love the Law
School Admission's Council.
So we'll talk a little bit
about our relationship,
but I'll remind everyone to go on to,
whether you're watching this
on YouTube, or Facebook,
and go on the message boards,
ask any questions you'd like
of Kellye and myself and
Kellye is expert on all things
law and law school, so I don't think
we're actually gonna
be giving legal advice,
but careers (laughing) careers in law,
maybe we will I don't
know ask us anything,
ask us anything.
But Kellye maybe a good place to start
is what is the Law School
Admission's Council?
- Well we love to basically help students
find their way to law school.
We think of ourselves as an organization
that helps advance equity in law
and we help candidates find a good match
when they're looking for a law school
and make sure that we
provide the support they need
to continue their enrollment journey.
You know Sal a lot of people
don't have lawyers in their family.
You know I'm a first
generation college grad,
and law school grad, and so
we really try and reach out
and provide a lot of information
and build the pipeline for justice.
- And most famously, the
Law School Admission's Test
which actually I took, I was
pre-law for a period of time,
maybe we'll go there.
But I'm curious 'cause
you know one of the things
that I look to do in these live streams
is just understand how our guests
ended up in the path they
are in and you mentioned
you're a first generation
college graduate,
what got you into the law profession?
What was kind of your career arc
from maybe thinking about going into law
to now being the head of the
Law School Admission's Council?
- Sure, well it's a little convoluted
because I started my life out
wanting to be a quarterback
on an NFL team, but my dad told me
I was a little short for that
so I should think up something else.
But in all seriousness I
was very avid into sports
when I was in high school and in college
and so it really wasn't until
I was a sports reporter,
and so I majored in journalism,
and then I found a class
called, Communications Law,
that I just fell in love
with and from that minute on
I knew I really wanted to
think about law school.
So I had a little time
in-between undergrad and law
when I worked in sales and marketing
and then went to law school
and have been so happy I did.
There are so many things
you can do with a law degree
and I've really enjoyed
being in this profession.
- And what was it about that
course in Communications Law
that got you hooked?
- You know we were asked
to go to the law library
and to find it on the campus and to go in
and read a famous case that
was about what's called,
liable, which is when you
say something negative
about a public figure and
could you be held responsible
for damages for that.
This case is called, "New
York Times versus Sullivan,"
and it's a famous one and
we were supposed to find it
and read it.
And I don't know really still what it was
but the minute I walked
in that law library
and I started reading that case
I realized the law's made up of stories,
you know, everyone has
a story and these cases
are the stories of times
when people may have had
a difficult time in their life,
or a challenging issue, and
so I loved reading their story
and seeing how the law can
help people find a voice
and find justice.
- And then how did that
trajectory keep going?
I actually felt similar things.
I took a business law class
while in business school
and I just was enamored by it
and obviously I was pre-law
for a moment in undergrad too
so I was definitely intrigued.
I read that book, "One L," and
I was really intrigued by it
but the, so how did you go from law school
to where you are now?
What was the, you know, your path?
- Well and let me just say
I know you keep pretty busy
and we love what you do,
but I can still talk to you
about law school, you know.
- My mom might like that,
law and medical school.
- That's right, exactly.
So I really enjoyed law school and I went
to Indiana University
in Bloomington, Indiana
which is where I'm from
and I was so fortunate
to grow up in a town with
a big state university.
And I went there undergrad and law school
and after law school I had the honor
to clerk for a federal judge
and I learned a lot during that year
about watching the judges hear the cases
and the lawyers argue the cases.
And I decided then that
I really was interested
in being in the teaching side of law.
There were things about
legal education that I liked,
but also things I thought could be better
and so I was interested
in being a law professor.
So I started my career teaching law school
and was a professor teaching classes
in the business law area,
and also in the law and inequality area.
Things like race and law, gender and law,
law and sexuality, and
really enjoyed that.
After a few years I was asked to serve
as the dean of the law
school where I was teaching
and I did that for about five years
and then I became
the dean of the University
of Washington's School of Law
for eight years prior to coming to
the Law School Admission Council.
And I was really intrigued by
the Law School Admission Council
'cause I had always tried to
work for educational equity.
I believe so strongly in
the power of education
and so this is a place
where we can really help
even the playing field and help candidates
advance their educations.
- Yeah no and I definitely
wanna get into that
talking about, we're already
getting a lot of questions
on YouTube about the LSAT and COVID,
but before we get to all of that
I'd love your thoughts on
what are some of the misconceptions
about the law career and stereotypes,
I guess what are accurate stereotypes
and what are less then
accurate stereotypes?
- (laughing) Well I think
one of the first things
I would say about that is that many times
when people think about what is a lawyer,
what comes to mind first
is perhaps a judge,
or a lawyer who is in court,
and that is part of what lawyers do,
but lawyers are also, I like to say,
you know, problem solvers in every field,
and they're also in many
ways referred to as sometimes
as engineers for justice.
You know the law is what gives our world
the possibility to thrive
by enforcing contracts,
and making sure people
keep their commitments,
so really lawyers work in every
single field that there is.
And you know I like to say
that if you think of a
university, or the world,
law's kind of at the middle, the hub,
every other thing has a connection to it.
And so no matter what your
passion, if it's environment,
or civil rights, or music,
or representing athletes,
or arguing in court, or
building businesses up,
and helping technology firms thrive,
lawyers do all those things and more.
- I like that phrase you mentioned,
engineers for justice.
You know I remember being surprised
when I was an undergraduate and I said,
"maybe I'll go into law,"
and I remember I started taking
practice tests for the LSAT
and I was like, "this is like
a computer science exam."
You know it has these
deductive reasoning problems,
these games, and obviously
some reading comprehension and logic.
Why do you think that's, why
do you think that's the core
of the LSAT, this like logic,
this deductive reasoning,
et cetera, I mean it appealed to me
as someone who had a very strong math
and engineering background--
- Yeah.
- And most people don't
see that connection.
- No, it's true, but the math majors
do really well in law school
and so do music majors
and so do many majors.
I mean one of the fun
things about law school
is that it takes people from every major
and all of them can drive.
So I think really, you
know, the LSAT is designed
to test the basic skills that it takes
to be successful in law school
and so it's not just a test
it's a way to build your skill
that you're gonna need when you get there.
And we've loved having the free test prep
through the Khan Academy because
we know that really helps
that skill building.
But Sal lawyers are, in many ways,
they're creative problem solvers.
They have to learn to
think really creatively
and to be able to, what I sometimes call,
look around corners.
In other words, what comes
next, what's gonna happen next,
how do you navigate uncertainty?
And so the skills that the LSAT test
are exactly the ones that one needs
to be able to do well as a lawyer
and those are things like
reading really critically
and understanding what you're reading,
thinking with reason and logic,
being able to reason from evidence,
and so those are the skills
that'll really help you be
of great use to your clients
because you'll be able to help
them solve their problems.
- No and I really like your point.
You know I think all too often
we either perceive ourselves,
or we perceive other people
as oh, they're math people,
they're science people, they're, you know,
they're eloquent their law people,
that's kind of one of the stereotypes,
or they're a good writers,
whatever it might be,
but the reality is, I always like
to give the example of Abraham Lincoln.
Abraham Lincoln obviously practiced law
but he thought to make
himself a better lawyer
he actually learned all
of the geometry proofs
in Euclid's elements.
And actually, James
Garfield, another lawyer,
he actually has a novel,
"Proof of Pythagorean Theorem,"
which he did while sitting
in the U.S. House of Representatives
so there's actually more cross-connections
then I think most people realize.
You know talking about our
relationship with Khan Academy,
the LSAT, and we'll talk more about that,
but you know one question from
YouTube, Mark Murray asked,
"how can we increase diversity
in the legal profession?"
So I'd love your take on that generally
and then I'd also love your take on how
hopefully our partnership
might play a role there?
- Sure, well diversity and equity
are so critical for law
because our legal profession
really needs to mirror society
so that people trust it and
so that we can really see
all the issues that
arise in a diverse world.
So the Law School Admission Test
and the Law School Admission Council,
our whole origination
story is around equity.
We were formed to help
even the playing field
so that it didn't depend
just on who you knew,
or which school you went to,
you could actually show
the skills you have
and be able to get attention
for what you deserve,
which is how you think
about complex problems.
So we really prioritize building
the pipeline to law school
because as I noted it's not always clear
that some people know
how to go to law school,
some people know that pathway,
some people have good
mentors, others may not.
And so we really try
and build the pipeline
and open that window up
so we can say, you know,
"we need your voice in law too."
And the more diverse those voices in law,
the more law will get closer
to that quest for equal justice
and that's what we all strive for
is to really merge law and justice
and so we know that diversity and equity
are critical parts of that.
- And a related question
from YouTube, Layeti asks,
"how does the LSAC support and encourage
first generation low-income students
to apply for law school,"
and I'll just add to that, you know,
you said you said you
were a first generation
college student and law student,
what would you tell to students out there
who are thinking, "well
it's kind of intriguing,
it seems like a great
profession, but it's,
you know after undergrad
it's three more years,
I'm probably gonna have to incur debt,
tuition doesn't seem cheap,"
what would you tell them if
they're thinking about it?
- You know I think the
most important thing
I would tell them is we really need you.
Coming out of the COVID crisis
and with all of the
struggles our world has
for equality and for justice,
we really need voices like
yours in the legal profession.
So I want you to know that
the students who do go,
it is an important investment,
but they're really glad they did.
The careers are very
diverse and fulfilling
and we do a lot to help you
on that enrollment journey.
We have the free LSAT prep
through the Khan Academy,
also at LSAC.org we have
a lot of resources there
to help candidates understand
how to navigate that pathway
and then we work with
our member law schools
and they all do a lot of outreach
and what we call pipeline building too
to help introduce
students to what it means
to go to law school and
how to do that well.
And I think that one of the
things is just so critical
is that lawyers are
really a wonderful group
about mentoring new students
and so we love to share
our actual thoughts
about what it means to be in law
because some people I think
have too narrow a view
of what it means to be a lawyer.
One of the best examples
I like to give of that Sal
is that I'll often hear
someone say, "I have three kids
and one of them they just
argue with me all the time,"
so that, I told them,
"hey go to law school."
Well what I wanna say is yes that person
may wanna go to law school
and do well as an advocate
but if one of those
children's a peace maker
we need you too, law is a
peace-making profession as well.
It builds a lot of common understanding,
it builds agreement, negotiation,
it finds ways to bring people together
and move forward collectively.
So whether you're the one who argues,
or you're the peace maker,
there's room for you in law.
- I'll just doubly underline that.
We actually have great internal council
here at Khan Academy,
her name's Julia Cowles,
and what I appreciate about her
is a lot of people have these stereotypes
that lawyers are, you know
they're always risk adverse,
or they're trying to stick
it to the other person,
or they're trying to kind
of overwhelm everyone
with really hard to understand terminology
and so everyone feels a little bit lost.
But the really great lawyers,
and I would consider
Julia to be one of them,
they know how to, your language
has to be precise as a lawyer
so that both parties--
- Right.
- Don't later say, "hey, I thought this?"
"No, no, no this is what we agreed to."
So if the language is precise
then everyone knows what's going to happen
and you're less likely to get
into a disagreement later,
but then also around the problem solving,
around can you make that language precise
but both parties don't think
that they're on kind of
the losing end of the deal,
and I think the best
lawyers are definitely
those problem solvers and
we definitely have one here
at Khan Academy.
A question from Facebook,
Loraine Alaura asks,
"would you consider
this a path for someone
who's middle aged?"
- You know I would.
My oldest student ever that graduated
was a doctor who graduated when he was 82
and he decided he wanted
a law degree, yeah,
I'll always remember him.
- Slight;y past middle age.
- He was awesome, so no,
it's true that many
people go to law school
right after college, but I had
almost six years in-between
undergrad and law school and many people
have more years than that.
And so it's a great profession
and honestly when you've
worked in some other discipline
many times you can then
use what you learned there
and merge it with law and
enhance your career that way.
So law school really does welcome people
from very diverse backgrounds, you know,
any major, any kind of, many
ages and the other thing
that's so important to that I wanna say
is that we also are
working with our schools
and we and our schools
really are serious about it
when we say we welcome diverse students,
we mean that widely.
View point, race and ethnic diversity,
and also a key area today
is disability rights,
and that's something that
we've been working really hard
to open doors for opportunity
to more candidates
who need accommodations in testing,
or need accommodations in
pursuing their educations.
- Yep, and from YouTube just
going into this COVID crisis,
I'm curious generally how you're coping
and how the whole
organization, legal profession,
but Lainie asks specifically,
"how is LSAC administering the LSAT
and the law school
application during COVID-19?"
- Yeah that's a great question
and we had to move very quickly
to take the law school
admission test into a format
that could be administered remotely.
So once we realized that COVID
was going to restrict travel
and gatherings for some time
we couldn't give the test in the field
so our developers and
personnel worked day and night
to convert the LSAT to a system
that can be delivered and
you can take it from home
with remote proctoring.
And that's begun and
that way we can make sure
the candidates continue
their enrollment journey
so it's really important
for us to be able to do that
and we're gonna do that
as long as we need to
while this crisis is on.
The other thing we've done
is that we've been horrified
by how much this crisis
has affected the world
in different ways, based
on again, inequality,
and so we've really been
redoubling our efforts
on diversity and equity.
We've been doing a lot of
webinars for candidates
and also for our schools
to try and support
everyone through this time,
but that's a really good question
and what might have taken
two years to do we were able
to really do very quickly
'cause we needed to.
We had the help and I was really proud
of how LSAC responded.
- And just following up on that,
what are trends, or are there trends
that you think are going to
happen because of COVID-19?
Do you think applications will go up,
they'll stay the same,
do you think more people
are thinking about graduate school?
- Yeah, I think that we're gonna see
strong demand for education.
I mean obviously there's a
lot of uncertainty right now
about what will the fall look like
and will it be, will people
be back to campus or not,
will it still be that
everyone will need to be
learning remotely for awhile?
But many students are familiar with that,
they're comfortable with it
and so we're seeing still
very, very strong demand
for legal education for this coming fall
and then the cycle where
people start to think about
applying for next fall's
beginning as well,
and again, it's still very strong.
And I think that one of the areas
that I've always encouraged
students to think about
is in timing, when do I go to law school,
is always think about,
well what's my option,
and right now the economy
is fairly disrupted,
you know in many areas severely,
and so I think that in a time
when employment's difficult
investing in education is
a really great solution.
And so I'm hoping and anticipating
that we'll still see a very strong demand
for legal ed and I'm glad
of that because we need it.
This crisis has really shown so many areas
that lawyers are gonna
have to help rebuild
and the rule of law needs to be respected
and strong and the devastation
that's been wrought by this pandemic,
and continues to be, is something lawyers
are gonna have to help
with and help repair.
- Yeah, and how do you see,
what are law schools
talking about right now
in terms of campus openings,
are they just following whatever their,
the university they're a part of doing?
Can you have an effective legal education
if the first semester, or the first year
is done over a video
conference of some kind?
- You know it's a hard question
because legal education is a
personalized form of education.
We don't do a lot of just lecturing,
we really engage with students
and have a lot of discussion,
we do a lot of hands-on
experiential education
where you're actually
working with real clients
and solving real problems.
So it has taken the
creativity of law schools
and they've responded in amazing ways
and had to respond as
we all did so quickly.
So I know this year I was
teaching law and leadership
at Villanova and so one day
I walked out of my classroom
not realizing I wouldn't
be able to walk back in
and we quickly took the course online.
Well that's being done
all across the world
and I think that as the fall comes,
since the schools have had even more time
to prepare for that, we'll see
an even stronger version of that
if it's not possible to bring
the students back to campus.
And right now I wish I
had an answer to that,
and everyone does.
I think that everyone is
preparing to try and bring
some form of education back to campus,
but that's something that
the schools and universities
are working closely with
government officials on too
to make sure it's safe to do so
because obviously the safety
of students is paramount.
So I think that there's a lot
of contingency planning happening,
some of you know, maybe some in person,
some online, what if it has to stay online
for a certain amount of time.
But I really feel a lot of confidence
in the enormous work the schools are doing
to prepare for that and
they care about the students
and they'll put them
first and do well by them.
- Yeah, no that's super
helpful and I don't think
anyone really knows how this--
- No.
- Next year's gonna play out,
but I think everyone's doing
pretty heroic jobs I mean.
A somewhat random question from YouTube,
Maha Kerkowitz, it says, "do
you know Ruth Bader Ginsburg?"
- (laughing) I certainly
know of her and I've met her
and had the great pleasure
of hearing her speak
a number of times and what a
wonderful figure for our world
and I admire her so very much,
not only her work as a Justice,
but the work she did
as a lawyer before that
as an advocate for women and the law
and an advocate on gender
equity more broadly.
So she's one of the real
heroes of justice I think
for many of us today.
- Yeah, just as a final question,
I'll just kind of group a
bunch of these questions.
You know there's some questions like,
"is law school hard," "or
how can I get through it,"
you know I think there's these,
you see in the movies these
people piling over these
seemingly dense books and they
imagine that's law school.
Someone who's an engineer,
Pria B.'s talking about,
"would I make a good lawyer?"
So you know just maybe
parting thoughts on anyone
who's like, "well law seems interesting,
but it seems hard,"
whatever that might mean.
What would you tell them,
what advice would you give,
or just life advice generally?
- Yeah, so I guess in
terms of law school itself
let me say that when I started law school
I had no idea what to expect
and I was worried it would be so hard
and something that could be out of reach,
but I wanna say that it is
really supportive today.
Legal education has changed a lot
from the "One L" book or
"The Paper Chase" movie
you might have seen
and the faculty members
are so supportive and
there's great infrastructure
for student support, and academic support,
career support, you name it.
So I really know that today
law students can thrive
and they get the support that they need.
Now that's not to say that it isn't
a rigorous form of education.
Much of it's value is that it is
and you will learn to
think hard in law school
and you will learn to really
contribute to the world
in so many ways and to really help people.
I think it's hard when
you get a law degree
and you get your license
you now have a license
to help people, to make
change in the world,
to do good in the world,
and that's something
that I really think most of us
really wanna find an avenue for.
We see the ways that our world,
as beautiful it is in some ways,
is broken in many others
and we need to repair that.
We need to work to make sure that everyone
has a chance to thrive in this world
and that's really what law does
it tries to make sure that everyone
has a chance to flourish.
So I think if you have a passion
for wanting to make the
world a better place
there's really no better
investment you can make
then learning the law and
following your passion
in whatever direction that takes you.
- You know Kellye you've inspired me
and so thank you, thank you so
much for being a part of this
I think you've just inspired a good chunk
of new future lawyers who
can hopefully be the type
that can bring justice
to the world for us all.
- Well I think they can and
I wanna say thanks to you,
you know you and the Khan Academy
that you inspire all of us
and educational equity is so critical
and so thanks for all you do
to make that so broadly available.
We really love our partnership with you
and look forward to it continuing.
- Likewise, thank you so much Kellye.
- My pleasure, great to be with you.
- So thanks everyone for joining
I thought another very
inspiring live stream guest,
especially if you're thinking
about the legal profession
and I look forward to
seeing y'all tomorrow
where we're going to have
the superintendent of Miami-Dade on
so that should be a really
interesting conversation.
I'll see y'all tomorrow.